[Music]
[Applause]
mike trico danica patrick no relation
dale earnhardt jr
uh just some of the uh crew that's going
to be covering the indianapolis 500 on
nbc and peacock coming up this weekend
junior uh joins us now
uh are you at indy right now
i am i'm in the infield uh getting ready
for uh we got a practice here uh coming
up in a bit so getting ready to
to see a little bit of cars on track
do they let you take a spin could you
take a spin if you wanted to in a car
i don't think so i think that uh
at this point in the weekend the race is
sunday i think that um all those kind of
shenanigans they might be able to have
that might be that would happen earlier
in the month but things prove things
getting pretty serious now that we're
just a few days away what's the
difference driving-wise if i said you
were gonna drive nascar formula 1 or
indy
well i think that
you know
to be quite honest with you i feel like
that
you know f1
uh
has always sort of
felt like the most elite form of racing
in terms of drivers and and
you know where if you're young and
you're thinking man i want to become a
you know a championship driver what form
of motorsport would you think is the
most elite i think a lot of people would
say f1
any cars making a uh resurgence and and
and popularity and
uh racing and personalities in this
board of indy cars is is on up on the on
the upswing
so it's it's uh it's having some some
good momentum right now and
um you know nascar is where i grew up in
and i'm always going to have a special
place in my heart for stock cars and and
and all the history that
that my family has in that but uh
but skill level wise you'll live life
well i mean they're all different
disciplines it's kind of uh you know
i think if you took
the best driver
out of each
uh series they might all not they might
not have that same success in the other
cars because they drive so differently i
know that formula one in any car are
more similar obviously than a nascar cup
car but so that would probably be you
know driving a cup car would be super
foreign i think for a guy like
hamilton
or or scott dixon they would figure it
out they would find a way to become
become competitive but we're watching um
you know jimmy johnson struggling
indycar
uh seven-time champion in nascar uh and
that shows that
uh you know you just don't unplug from
one series and plug into the other one
and and become successful right away it
uh you you almost have to grow up from
the very beginning early stages of your
life at five ten years old and and have
that decision of where you want to go
in that moment right and be working
toward that goal and living that goal
your whole life to
uh you know you don't you don't become a
you don't start it at 35 years old and
decide you're going to be an indycar
champion you know yeah that starts at 5
10 15 years old what if you told your
dad at age 18 hey i'm gonna i'm gonna do
indycar
uh
yeah i think he would probably think
that's that's impossible because
i had no
connections i had no
networking he knew nothing about that
uh type of racing and how how how would
i get involved how would i start to to
create that path for myself so
um
you know we were so entrenched in stock
cars that that would probably be
very impractical for me but can those
skills be like did you get those from
your father
or do you just get it from driving
well i think that there are some things
you're born with that actually help you
know
absolutely help you different attributes
phys you know physical attributes and
whatnot
you know great peripheral vision and
things like that so there are some
things you're born with but i think that
when you
are born into a situation where you're
around it all the time and you're
observing as a child what you're seeing
on the racetrack or what your father
might be doing if you grow up around the
racetrack you attain
a lot of knowledge at a very young age
about what you're seeing and you know
you know so
when you jump into a race car even at a
young age it all makes sense because you
you saw it happen
uh you you know so things come to you
quicker your learning curve is much uh
less steep when you grow up around the
racetrack as a child
yeah i'm curious about formula one
that that tv show on netflix
kind of opened the door
for people to kind of understand like it
became younger demo seems to be like wow
that's kind of cool that
like
can it be based off of that a tv show
that all of a sudden i mean formula
one's been around for decades yeah and
it feels like people
you know became an overnight success
it really did uh um that certainly
is what happened
uh
and it has made you know formula one
like you say it was already a global
uh iconic
brand
and um
at least i can say in the united states
that the netflix series has made
many more many more fans for for formula
one a lot of people are watching formula
one in the united states that never
watched it before because of that series
and
that has really opened the eyes i think
of of all motorsports
nascar indycar how can we
sort of recreate that same magic and
there are a lot of things happening
behind the scenes where i think nascar
is
from you know i know i know in the inner
circles of nascar they're trying to work
on some similar you know content
that might have the same impact on on
fan engagement so
it's uh
you know formula one is incredible
but i think that the series really
brought that to everybody's living room
and allowed people easy easy access to
just how special
that series and those cars and drivers
are
and so other forms of motor sports can
follow suit could you do indy cars
you know in the united states and and
have tracks just like you have in
formula one what do you mean
that you just set up
you know i mean
that then yeah maybe expanded i should
say well yeah i mean they can they can
have it they can build a street course
pretty much anywhere um
you know and i think that uh
you know
formula one can
formula one has so much leverage you
know of course these you know cities
like miami would love to have 41 come
compete there so they'd do anything
right they'll make it happen it needs to
happen
so uh you know and i don't know i don't
know you know nascar and any car they
have some leverage you know nascar's had
some conversations with chicago about
having a street course there
uh around uh around the you know the old
stadium and so it's uh
everybody's having to think outside the
box you know nascar went to the coliseum
to race i never thought i'd see that and
uh over in la
so um i think the pandemic has really
made everybody open up to anything's
possible we shouldn't be really kind of
stuck to our traditions and what we
think is our lane right we can really
kind of let's go outside our lane a
little bit and do some things that
people thought we'd never do
and we're starting to see that a little
bit with nascar especially
dale jr will be part of nbc sports
coverage of the greatest spectacle in
racing alongside danica patrick and mike
trico coverage gets underway at 11 a.m
eastern on nbc and peacock did you ever
have any uh
issue with danica patrick any uh run-ins
no
danica used to drive for
me at junior motorsports for a couple
years before she went into the cup
series so
um i was just we had just we had dinner
meet her and mike had dinner last night
and i was telling her i remember when
she was running the atlantic series and
that's when i first saw her race uh
because those were on television and i
thought man she's so good
and i couldn't wait for her to move up
in the indy car and i was a so i was a
fan of danica's uh way back then
and when she decided to come to nascar
we were the team that she chose to to do
that you know to to try that challenge
with and so we were kind of
um we were kind of lucky because she she
she made our she made our company at
junior murder sports a lot better
uh and um the experience she was good
you know we had a great we had some
great runs and she was competitive
um
and then she moved on the cup and drove
for stewart haas and and
and the rest is history but uh
yeah we never had any problems on the
racetrack i raced with her a few times
but um we we did have one uh at kentucky
i ran out of brakes
uh
yeah the brakes were uh we were having
an issue or break wait wait wait wait
wait
how do you run out of brakes
well the brakes
the brakes cooked like uh i got either a
bunch of debris on the grill or whatever
and it cooked the brake fluid and so the
brake pedal would go to the floor and
the brakes would not slow down the car
and so i was falling back to the pack
and i'd been running behind her for a
little while
and i was running uh you know we went
into a corner and she slowed down for
the corner and i didn't and i ran in the
back of her and put her in the fence and
uh we ran into each other on pit road
she was mad
and uh she got out of the car it was
like you know i don't know what he was
doing and and but we i told her
afterwards i said man how many breaks
couldn't stop i had you know you you
were in front of me and i hit you and it
was just a bad deal like if you didn't
have any breaks you should have got off
the track
right
you didn't have any you know like
emergency blinkers that you can put on
in your nascar there was nothing i could
do i didn't think other than get off the
race track uh but you know sometimes you
try to do whatever you can to stay out
there and compete but that was the only
time i can remember us ever really
having any kind of on track you know
disagreement
the noise of daytona
as opposed to indy
what's the
difference the noise the sound
oh man i mean the cars sound completely
different
um
the the indy cars are flying you know
they're doing a
245 miles an hour almost at the end of
the back straightaway and qualifying
wow and i'll be on the peacock pit box
at the end of turn one at the end of pit
road
uh in turn one
and
the cars are coming by they look like
airplanes going right you know that are
floating across the ground that's really
what they look like
um they have a lot of similarities in
shape and so forth and so they kind of
they kind of look like fighter jets
going around the racetrack and the speed
is insane so how much faster can they go
probably i mean they could probably go a
lot faster
i mean
yeah i don't know 250 260
they could probably go quite a bit
faster there's really no
what's the fastest you've driven
an indy car
uh i've never drove an indy car but i
ran 220 at michigan
in a cup car
at the end of the straightaway in
probably 2008 or so we were they repaid
uh michigan and we were flying around
that racetrack averaging about a 204
205 lap so uh 220 at the industry you
really can't tell a difference that's
why he's going to ask you because
sometimes baseball players will go i'll
say 95 miles an hour and then 100 miles
an hour how much of a difference yeah it
feels like once you're around 180
it all feels the same from that point on
um now i don't know 240
might feel quite a bit different than
180. i never went 240 but um
yeah 200
180 to 220 it's all kind of the same
really it all slows down and you if
you're running lap after lap after lap
and you know mentally you start to sort
of
slow everything down in your mind how
important is your eyesight having good
eyesight being a driver super poor super
important because the tracks have a
bunch of imperfections in them cracks uh
seals like little little lines where
they've sealed the track um bumps and
cracks and whatever right and there's
there's the apron the white line or
yellow line down there below that you
want to put the car you really want to
put this car
within inches you're trying to hit marks
really that are so
specific
and if visually you can't see
all of those things uh you're really at
a disadvantage so
uh when i was when i was a cup racer
having having great 20 20 vision not
needing you know glasses or or or
contacts or anything i thought was was a
was an advantage
and when my sight you know when i turned
40 in my eyesight started
changing
uh when i started holding my phone
further and further out and then my my
arms were no longer long enough
um that was i became a disadvantage you
really you know you see drivers like joe
logano and harvick wearing glasses now
in the car well it's because they can't
you have to read the dash better to be
able to see the the digital dash and all
the things much clearer
but also to be able to see some of the
specific
uh nuances of the surface of the
racetrack because you really want to try
to make sure you're putting your car
exactly to the edge of where you want to
be in those corners
maybe we create a shield for the helmet
that's prescription
that'd be nice yeah
i mean i i think that um
some of these guys are getting up toward
their 40s or even over 40 years old
they're gonna need some some
they probably some of them more will
need glasses and they don't even know it
i didn't know i need glasses until i
picked up my mom's one day and i was
like holy moly this is like hd what have
i been doing oh by the way i uh i have
the um
the accident with you and danica oh you
got it uh so
she she said
to her
team go bleep yourself
i mean really if you don't have any
breaks why would you drive in underneath
me weren't you thinking about that maybe
the corner before that what a ass bleep
yeah
yeah hey um when we're when you know
when we climb that car and put a helmet
on we're all drivers and we all have bad
bad language
so that was well be careful with your
language this weekend though junior okay
i will i won't worry i don't have to
worry about it i ain't putting a helmet
on this well you're next to danica i
just don't want something you know if
you bump into her i told you we went to
dinner last night okay
all right okay all right
uh hey thanks for joining us tell uh
danica and uh tarico we said hello i
will good to talk to you thank you
that's dale jr he'll be part of the nbc
sports coverage of the greatest
spectacle in racing it starts at 11 a.m
eastern